welcome back to CBS this morning we are
following breaking news from NASA and
the Russian space program an astronaut
and a Russian cosmonaut were forced to
make a dramatic emergency landing this
morning in Kazakhstan just moments after
takeoff for the International Space
Station Russia's space agency says it
booster rocket when the Soyuz space
capsule apparently failed Jonathan
Vigliotti spawned developments from
London Jonathan good morning to you
sounds very scary and very dramatic as
you mentioned good morning Gail US
s-tronic Hague and Russian cosmonaut
Alexei of Chinon were rescued without
injuries in Kazakhstan after making that
amazing emergency landing they had
launched earlier this morning headed for
the International Space Station when
photos captured what looked like an
explosion according to NASA the launch
had an issue with the booster rocket a
few seconds after the first stage of
separation that led to what's called a
ballistic descent mode at dizzying and
potentially fatal downward spiral and
the tweet Russian space agency said the
emergency rescue system worked over the
past few years the Russian space
industry has suffered a series of
problems including the loss of other
spacecraft again though the headline
right now both astronauts are safe and
with rescuers after this morning's
failed takeoff Gale glad everything's
okay thank you Jonathan Vigliotti in
London there's always at moment guys
when they take off and you see that big
burst of flames and you're hoping is
everything okay yeah you realize how
risky this is exactly no remember the
challengers always poor he's not